what's up reject nation I'm Greg no I'm
John wide awake it's 6:00 in the morning
I didn't just wake up one minute ago and
leave John waiting outside for 25
minutes
my style my phone was loud and clear
okay watch this Maleficent - mistress of
evil official trailer since we're so on
top of it especially myself today let's
get to it
five years ago I thought I'd lost you
forever there is no curse that could
ever turn me away for you
[Music]
getting married don't ruin my morning
[Music]
third pass which Marian no I wasn't
really asking nor was I love doesn't
always end well feasted trust me that
has proved you wrong who have done an
admirable job going against her own
nature to raise this child but now she
will finally get the love of a real
mother
tonight I consider
my
jealous obsessive
[Music]
you do not
awesome
looking creatures
tell me what happened there was another
creature
[Music]
spent years caring for a shoe
so to tell us you for I know he's
supposed to be in this right those those
like a whole army of Maleficent type
people okay so I think I know how this
is all gonna play out hear me out on
this guy's Maleficent all like
possessive doesn't want to rora to
evolve and grow and have this marriage
to this guy possessive jealous
the Maleficent this is all the evils
gonna be coming out of her she's I'm
gonna go to evil though because you know
it's this live action does not person
where she's the protagonist yeah that's
gonna start leading some conflict we're
gonna find the guy that Aurora is
engaged to that her family are really a
bunch of jerks that her family they're
actually evil so when she's with her
horn fairy family which i think is what
they're called whatever Maleficent is
with those guys they're gonna have to
unite in an epic battle against the evil
princes family and it's gonna be an
all-out war but even amongst you know
this whole journey
well episode will still have realized
some things about her behavior and
attitude and about having to let aurora
go just a little bit even though she was
kind of right about the the family being
jerks she was still kind of a jerk
herself that's how I think probably
especially because I read this morning
the Disney basically confirmed Michelle
Pfeiffer as an evil queen I was like why
would you confirm society cated me in
the tree right yeah it could be
misinformation but that's what I read
earlier no that's exactly how it's gonna
play out I'd be very surprised at what
any other way yeah I wouldn't be too and
I'm like I like the idea of what these
movies are these Maleficent movies I
like the idea of taking a villain and
recontextualizing them in a gray area
but I also think that at least the
subtitle is sort of trying to have its
cake and eat it too I always feel like
this particular series for whatever
reason like wants you to believe that
she's like super evil she's not
yes she is you know she's evil because
she wants to take care of a woman I
think she knows what the spectacle looks
great I mean the thing is like I've been
seeing a lot of different fantasy pieces
so I'm a little bit like you said like
grouped and then you got these vines
growing which reminded me of several
things I do like the darker side of
Disney generally speaking I don't think
we get to see it in a focal way as much
you know we're like the main characters
yeah hero the imagery of these trailers
and Angelina Jolie's poised is always
the most alluring thing regardless of
how the movie looks like Angelina Jolie
always looks amazing yeah man natalie is
great in this role I kind of feel like
it would be a little cooler if the movie
was about the horn fairy people and
exploring that instead of like a cool
side detail that they're gonna introduce
at some point to get her out of a jam
midpoint or the all is lost point that's
for the mythological expansion would be
that's one of those details that I in a
trailer like this see and kind of wonder
warily about whether they're going to
use that as something that's actually
gonna expand the story and actually be a
worthwhile fantasy element or if this is
gonna be like what if there were more
Maleficent see more of them let's have
more of them so they can like help her
out and stuff and we can get a cool
action scene with a lot of people with
wings and horns I hope that it's not
just some kind like got it I just
figured out more than okay here we go
those people horn fairies are gonna be
like good folk when they defeat the real
evil
I think mistress of evil is implying
towards Michelle Pfeiffer
you know how the Dark Knight is really a
play hunt also Harvey Dent not Hispanic
and they're doing here don't want Andhra
so I think that she will let aurora go
and she's gonna go off with a horn fairy
folk at the end and she's no longer
gonna be looking after Aurora
and then part three is gonna be about
her campaigning for horn fairy rights
mm-hmm
it's gonna be a play on quality and
feminism led by Chabot - oh yeah look
how evil she is and then the point is
actually just gonna be Lulu we just want
to coexist Laura's gonna save the day
right after that yeah Disney's releasing
a hell of a lot of trailers we got that
liking coming out we want stuff to play
yeah before the movie yeah we got to get
our whole slate out there so no one
forgets about the mouse yes but it's
cool to have like an action fantasy
that's all about mothers I guess that's
kind of Annie I just said I just
realized that part of it you know what's
cool is to have Michelle Pfeiffer and
Angelina Jolie going toe to head yeah
like DeNiro versus Pacino but women yeah
oh we've been waiting for this mashup
yeah all for so long I have a feeling
that some big takeaways I'm really gonna
have with this film I don't think the
trailers really giving me Elle Fanning
and Angelina Jolie and their
relationship is gonna be really felt I
mean the fact that the first Maleficent
came out a while ago yeah Elle Fanning
yeah that's obviously cuddles yes she's
also really evolved as an actress and
she's featured quite a bit in this
trailer I think the core heart of it is
gonna be their dynamics with one another
and I think that there's gonna be a big
take away between their performances and
I think she'll it's a logic far is gonna
play a character that most people can
play yeah that's the thing is like he's
the one new addition in the cast that we
actually get like a good glimpse at
because I think like ed skrein is in
this and a few other you know it yeah
people right now when I watch this
trailer I want to be like oh this is
really cool and I want to get intrigued
but it just reminds me of Snow White and
the Huntsman favorites
I like this trailer selling us on an
overall very personal conflict but I
also think the trailers trying to market
it to be a bigger epic than it actually
is because it feels like it's probably
gonna be a little bit more intimate and
not
or dramatic a little less like we got to
gear up that battle I'm sure there's a
big third act finale that thing at the
end like they love these trailers when
they're in like whatever looks like some
kind of Citadel and they're things
flying like that's got to be the finale
but I'm also sure it's probably gonna be
a little funnier this is the guy who do
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales the best one funniest yeah the
furniture isn't totally apparently they
love the success of that movie so much
they say you're gonna have you direct
this sequel my buddy let's we want you
to direct our female-centric and tigers
we don't think it was your fault that
movie didn't do so well
take this sequel instead of it I think
it's cool that this movie is getting a
sequel because the first Maleficent was
one of the early live-action adaptations
and one of the more different ones
that's not just seeking to copy as
original it was different because it was
so early on - you know because it's not
exactly the adaptation of Sleeping
Beauty whoo pretty much is but it's got
that at least that fun hook of like what
if Maleficent wasn't as bad as what if
this was wicked in the day and age where
we have you know just weird new genre of
live-action adaptations of Disney
Animated Classics
I think it's cool to go back to one of
the movies that kind of launched all
this I don't think anyone has talked as
long about this we're gonna break it all
down as this is for us hey guys thanks
for tuning and are you excited for the
mistress of almost evil to come out guys
can subscribe the reject nation hey
click that notification Bell check us
out on patreon I guess you know we got
so many things TV show reactions to
belongs and someone reaction highlights
include clinically Q&A I want to give up
I want to give a patient a day shout out
to a lovely lady named Brianna
Davidson John don't mess this up this
time she pledged to the patreon strictly
to watch the Cobra Kai stream along I'm
so flattered by that I really do
appreciate you because people don't
often tell me John I signed up on page
just to watch along with you Cobra Kai
season 2 was a journey of sorts but I
had a blast watching it and just knowing
that you were there enjoying along with
me actually really forms of my heart I
mean I don't know what I'm gonna do now
I hope I can maintain your interest
season 2 is over we're gonna wait for
season 3 I'm gonna Drive myself crazy
being awake all night thinking what does
Briana watch comment in the comments of
this YouTube video and let me know what
series I should hop on next I'm gonna
try and watch everything and it's not
gonna go well thanks Briana much love
was a good shout out died did I do it I
might've try to make it a little more
personal maybe weaving some mistress of
evil things and all you know what you
are an antihero that's what I love about
you Briana